zoe kravitz dishes on living with nicole
kidman when she was engaged to her
rocker dad on a scale from one to ten
how much does she love me ten come on
Zoe him back in February Nicole opened
up Tonetta port A's digital magazine the
edit about reconnecting with her big
little eyes co-star the only child of
her former flame Lenny Kravitz Nicole
who was rumored to be engaged to the
rocker in the early 2000s never
confirmed the claims until her interview
in February
now the 28 year old is weighing in on
Nicole's revelation telling the edit
quote I think she forgot that no one
knew that Lenny and Zoe's mom The Cosby
Show actress Lisa Bonet divorced when
Zoe was five years old when she was 11
she moved to Miami to live with her
famous dad that's when she first met
Nicole quote I hadn't seen her in a long
time before big little eyes but there
was a point where we were all kind of
living together I was about 13 and she
would take me to see movies she was so
nice to me and it's still nothing but
love Nicole gushed about Zoe 2et at the
premiere for her new flick the beguiled
I've noticed and she was little so yeah
I've watched her grow up and she's
gorgeous no I mean she's not just on the
outside on the inside
[Music]